[Music]
what's happening there reject nation
thank you so much for clicking on this
video if you guys can go ahead and leave
a like that would be very much
appreciated so what we're gonna do today
with all the speculation are they doing
a new scene adding an end of andrew
garfield in the morbius movie now with
the delay is it at the pandemic that
delayed it or are they trying to push an
andrew garfield scene in there i have
spent way too much time obnoxiously
obsessing about trying to find all these
clues and then on this journey i ended
up putting together a list of all the
clues that i could find that showcase
that venom and morbius already take
place within the amazing spider-man
universe hey greg what's going on hey
it's ryan from screen crush look i just
wanted to say i i
heard you were gonna do like an easter
egg breakdown thing and i think that's
adorable but we think you should really
leave that to the professionals like us
don't embarrass yourself shut the [ __ ]
up ryanairy
shut the [ __ ] up all right guys let's do
this i got like i don't know eight to
ten clues here some are more obvious
easter eggs some are clues that i'm sure
you've already thought of i'm gonna talk
about some variants gonna talk about
some things were you guys already going
here so i could debunk this well maybe
this is actually not a debunk let's dive
into this guys i think you're gonna
enjoy this one so let's get the obvious
ones out of the way the ones that
obviously come to mind so the first one
on the list would have to be the oscorp
logo featured within the morbius trailer
so in the amazing spider-man and the
amazing spider-man 2 those buildings are
already different so if more bees does
take place in the amazing spider-man
universe this would just be oscorp's
third building
how many buildings do you need that's
what they do when they need to re-brand
after some crazy stuff with norman and
harry they gotta get a new building
every time extract the public discourse
but as we all know that's the same logo
from the amazing spider-man and of
course when the foe establishes a no way
home that there is no oscorp in the mcu
the other obvious clue would be in the
daily bugle newspaper in the morbius
trailer where the names black cat and
rhino are dropped now john oh yes in the
marvel cinematic universe is there a
black hat in rhino not in the mcu and
not in the raymies cu exactly just
amazing spider-man to our understanding
because yes felicia hardy played by who
played by felicity jones way to go john
was being set up to of course become
black cat and of course we saw paul
giamatti brilliant performance
understated performance subtle of the
rhino in the amazing spider-man 2. so
bam you got those out of the way now
this next clue i actually think is a
very key and very important one that
really does showcase that they are in
the same world and that is the
cinematography specifically the color
palette the lighting of them the mcu is
something that i'm sure a lot of you
guys have heard this criticism of is a
lot of them look the same despite the
fact that a lot of them are different
characters different genres they tend to
have a similar look and that's for a
really good reason and that's to
establish that they are within the same
world now if you look at the amazing
spider-man movies and if you look at the
venom movies you look at the morbius
trailer they all share this similar look
this similar blue color palette
aesthetic it's a very specific choice
color scheming is very specific it's
like in the matrix they always have this
green tint except for the matrix
resurrections but the major strokes you
always have this green tint the mcu
films tend to have a similar look not
always but generally and then here with
their sony spider-man universe they do
look similar in cinematography yeah
which i mean you could easily go it's
just light in color but if you think
about it too the sam raimi films have
their visual uniformity those were sony
movies and they could have easily kept
or just gone away from that they did
with the blue going past the tasm movies
they could have changed the color
palette again but they didn't so you
have morbius and venom looking and
resembling those colors that tone of
visuals so hey that's a pretty strong
clue i'd say that's right ryanairy all
right so the next clue on this list is
actually coming from the amazing
spider-man 2 i want to shout out hayden
king who did remind me about this little
easter egg in the film and it's actually
at the one hour three minute mark in the
movie when harry osborn literally
stumbles across some very important
secret files in the film they have a
list of projects that oscorp has going
on and one of them is venom storage
that's listed and another one is dr
morbius file as well already established
in the amazing spider-man universe
that's a list of easter eggs
yeah hold on hold this actually
it's gonna come down the line yeah
another clue the ravencroft institute
the ravencroft institute big part of the
spider-man world essentially the arkham
asylum of spider-man if you guys saw the
venom movies you know that they are
definitely in the event there's a whole
big ass
venom let there be content takes place
at the ravencroft institute the
ravencroft institute definitely exists
in the amazing spider-man films as well
but they are not in the sam raimi movies
to my understanding and they are not in
the marvel cinematic universe movies to
my understanding as well if i'm wrong
about that correctly but i was literally
like are they in there because i don't
remember that but they are in the
amazing spider-man films and before you
jump on your keyboard because it is true
the ravens craft an amazing spider-man
is in new york and the one in venom is
in california but just like with ozcorp
you might have multiple locations of a
place that deals with as high-powered
individuals as the ravencraft institute
does you'd probably want to have one on
either coast yeah at least yeah prisons
are a franchise that's right man the
same asylums are afraid we should open
one up ourselves arkham asylums and like
minnesota definitely
passive income all right this next
school in the list the venom post credit
scene and the spiderman no way home post
credit scene now we all thought that
they were building up venom to go fight
tom holland that doesn't seem like it's
gonna be the case if you combine the
scenes it's like if adam was in the mcu
for two minutes and it just seemed like
he was set up to leave behind the
symbiote a lot of people are theorizing
he's probably just going back into the
amazing spider-man universe i'd argue
that he's already in the amazing
spider-man universe i re-watch the
post-credits scenes at not one point
does he ever say or even indicate that
he's never heard of spider-man if you
watch that let there be carnage
post-credit scene yeah he's all
flustered by like what room am i in and
then spider-man pops up on the tv venom
takes over right away venom might have
some type of history with some
spider-man from a different universe or
whatever but tom hardy never ever states
like who is that guy who's spider-man
i've never heard of spider-man not one
point does he ever indicate that i think
a lot of us should sort of jump to that
conclusion and then yes in the
post-credits scene for no way home he
does say maybe i should go talk to this
spider-man guy he might have just
learned with everyone else like oh
spider-man's peter parker but he never
indicates once that he's never heard of
spider-man before it's a good point and
two i mean if you look at the math of
the movie i mean toby maguire obviously
got three films so there's part of that
but you know he brings three villains
with him andrew only brings two this
could be a clue that venom and andrew
garfield spider-man share the same
universe and we're just about to find
that out in the next installment so
here's another clue that i think a lot
of people have talked about and i just
kind of add on a little bit more to it
see in the morbius trailer they did have
that image that was going around was
really popular one from the trailers of
the toby maguire spider-man set murderer
on it created a lot of confusion he's
like okay that's weird it's a toby
maguire one murder maybe that's in
reference to tom holland being accused
of murdering mysterio but why is it the
toby maguire one i think a lot of clues
do point to this in spider-man no way
home he does have that speech where he
gets very emotional he's talking about
after the death of gwen stacy he tried
being the friendly neighborhood
spider-man and at some point he stopped
pulling his punches he got rachel maybe
he accidentally murdered someone without
a few people or a few yeah maybe he's at
this point in the franchise he's branded
as a criminal because obviously by the
time we catch up with him and no way
home some time has passed and two i mean
their suits kind of look similar so
maybe that could also be some kind of
gray area they're trying to ride at sony
i could see why they might mistakenly
put a different picture up there like
within the world of the movie because
it's not a photo of spider-man it's an
animated image while that image is based
off of toby maguire's suit it's
ultimately an animated image from the
spider-man ps4 game so one way they
could chalk it up is that someone
created this image someone designed this
rendering it's not an actual photo of it
it's an interpretation of the spider-man
suit so murderer could be slapped on for
andrew garfield as we've seen in every
freaking marvel trailer as of late and
especially the no way home trailer it's
really easy to remove characters yeah
it's really especially digitalized
digitized photos of people if you can do
that with characters who are moving in
trailers you could easily do that with a
photo maybe the spider-man ps4 game is
canon in the tasm universe let's not go
down at all
let's do it here's one that actually
really stood out to me a lot the fact
that we were pretty much made aware that
sony has been trying to get a sinister
six movie off the ground for quite some
time you got whatever's going on with
the mcu and then you got the what a lot
of people are just dubbing the
venomverse over at sony and sony's been
having plans to try to get a sinister
six movie off the ground for a while and
it seems pretty indicative that they are
building up to that you got morbius you
got venom you got craven the hunter and
then it's like who knows who's gonna
fill those other three slots for the
sinister six but amazing spider-man 2
did end with the character the gentleman
who was revealed in a trilogy of
spider-man novels i just learned this
recently so he's revealed to be the
super criminal the gentleman who is
assembling the sinister six so if this
does take place within the amazing
spider-man universe that's just another
clue that indicates towards that since
obviously if sony's gonna be doing a
sinister six it would be comprised of
the characters they have control over
and probably ones that they've
introduced up until this point rather
than surprising you with a whole new
roster so another one here this is
something that a lot of people were
pointing out as well is in spider-man no
way home it just sounded like a funny
line he does say he wants to find an
alien andrew garfield says that it's a
really funny line it's really it's part
of a moment and maybe it was improvised
putin really knows or maybe it was
indeed a up for a possible moment in
time where andrew garfield would get the
symbiote one moment in time
or he's able to fight venom and that was
a tease for what's to come yes it's both
i think it's a tease and if everybody
responds well which they have it will be
made reality that little boy in iron man
2 was always spider-man and then here's
something that i think can easily be
explained the ones that i feel like most
people would point to and go debunked
the daily bugle logo and vulture first
off it's just a logo
they could have updated their logo and
it just represents the sam raimi one
it's very likely that that could have
just been the case all right and then
two with vulture i think a very obvious
explanation for this could be he's just
a very the fact that we have jk simmons
playing different versions of jay jonah
jameson because the one in the sam raimi
films and the one in the mcu are
different jay jonah jameson's i think
they've made that abundantly clear and
now here with vulture it honestly could
just be the exact same case which i
think would actually kind of work partly
because of the business aspect of like
homecoming was made much more under the
sony umbrella than the current marvel
sony arrangement and also of all the
characters i feel like it wouldn't be
disappointing to introduce a variant
michael keaton vulture that's still the
vulture but just gets to have a new
character history exactly so
guys with that in mind do you think that
morbius and venom are actually tied into
the amazing spider-man universe are
there other clues that we completely did
not mention today that you think could
be totally added onto this list put it
down in the comments below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button hey
let's do a
michael linden if there's anybody at
this patreon who i think of when i hear
the word gentlemen it is you you are the
biggest gentleman here you are a
sophisticated friendly caring kind
person you've got great taste for the
finer things in life not just in cinema
but even in cinema you have a taste for
the high class fancy characters you
probably walk that walk in real life i
can imagine you in a snazzy hat some
kind of fedora or something like that
putting together your own sinister six
michael because if there's anything that
gentlemen do they don't get their hands
dirty they get other people to get their
hands dirty for him so uh hey i would
join your team i'll do your dirty work
i'll do anything you asked me to do
mikhail you just smile at me a couple
times you know show me that stare that
smolder of yours
i'm putty in your hands man stay calm
stay classy and we'll catch ya next
month hopefully and uh yeah
happy new year
yup
[Music]